oh
a
[Music]
it's not
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
shake this square world and blast off
for kicksville
public enemy number one is drug abuse
just say no
halting the drug problem in america is
like carrying water in a sieve
take my word for it this scourge will
stop there's now an understanding that
the war on drugs was an abject failure
you have to stop and ask yourself how
did we get here
we will build a wall
[Music]
i grew up in a town like happy days
there were any drugs no guns no violence
and when i went up to california my
intention was to go to long beach state
college and complete my degree in
marketing
suddenly everybody was smoking marijuana
and i saw the value in selling the
marijuana
more than getting high off of it
[Music]
my name is george jacob young spelled
j-u-n-g
okay and
what i'm known for
is
being one of the major drug smugglers
in the world
[Music]
the money was just rolling in
and
you know of course it was tax-free
but i became bored with that as a matter
of fact
i wanted more
i wanted more thrill more adventure
so i convinced my college buddies
to get involved let's get on to mexico
and get our own pot
[Music]
we went to a place called puerto
vallarta
[Music]
and couldn't speak spanish and after
five days we couldn't even find a joint
[Music]
my ego was kind of shrunk down to zero
and a little yellow volkswagen pulled up
out front the bar
and this little blonde girl got out and
she came right to our table she said you
know i've been watching you guys for
like five days she said you've asked
everybody in puerto vallarta for
marijuana except the police chief
she said you need help
i said yes i do
and she said i live with the guy who can
give you all the marijuana you want
and i said let's go
[Music]
we went over to meet him and he said are
you going to get it out of here
and i said
fly it he said you have a plane
and i lied and i said yes i do i said i
can get one i'll be back with it
so then it was time
to learn how to fly
[Music]
i did this for considerable amount of
time
and i was making
a ton of money
[Music]
but they finally caught up with me
i was looking out five years in the
federal system
[Music]
the judge was about to sentence me and i
got up i said
it's ludicrous that i
should be sentenced for taking a plant
across an imaginary line
and he said that may be true mri he said
unfortunately it's against the law
so i got the five years
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my mother grew up in this part of town
which was the only place that you can
actually smoke reefer you know have a
couple drinks
bet a little on numbers watch rooster
fights and maybe go and have a good time
with the prostitute
i'm talking about 1950s there were still
muddy streets horse-drawn
carriages my name is michael colemblanco
i'm the youngest surviving son of juan
griselda blanco
also known as the queen of cocaine
[Music]
she told me that she remember being so
poor she didn't have no shoes or sandals
and my mother said to herself the day i
have children i'm gonna make sure they
live in the lap of luxury
the neighborhood was divided between
these two local street gangs and she
started to date a kid from the other
part of the neighborhood pestanitas
pestanita ran bootlegging he ran a
couple prostitutes sold some weed
and he met this little girl
she was uh 14 when she fell in love with
him
they got married and
he introduced her to marijuana
they've been drug dealing together right
[Music]
they were getting money
but pestanitas told my mother we're
making peanuts here if we can get this
weed to new york
we could make a big load of money
[Music]
so they relocated to new york and they
started doing deals in new york
when they start making serious money my
mother goes back to colombia and she
meets a gentleman who was a club owner
and the gentleman tells him you might
want to think about this drug called
cocaine
this is jackson heights in the borough
of queens it's one of the places where
cocaine comes home to the united states
this has become the central distribution
point for majority of all the cocaine
distributed in northern united states
if you just stand here and watch these
people that's exactly what they're doing
right now
because they're doing business
in the early 70s
resell griselda becomes the queen of
queens
queens new york
[Music]
she's selling cocaine
my mother realizes that this is the
future
[Music]
cocaine was on the rise the demand was
starting to increase
at jfk airport the seizures were from a
pound or so or two pounds on the body to
two or three kilos in the suitcases
we were starting to see other methods
anything that could conceal cocaine was
starting to make its way in more
frequently
and brazil the blanco's fingerprint was
on that
i was sentenced to danbury federal
correctional institute
and
that was how i met the infamous carlos
later
khals was there for stealing cars and
shipping them illegally to colombia
i said well basically you're a car thief
and he said what about you and i said
i flew plane loads of pot out of mexico
he said do you know anything about
cocaine i didn't
he said you can buy it for three to four
thousand dollars a kilo in colombia
and i said well how much is it all for
the united states and he said
sixty thousand a kilo
and i said you know what goes
i think you and i got to go into
business together
[Music]
[Music]
brazilda entrepreneured the cocaine
industry as we know it from the jungle
to the street corner to the nightclub to
the household my mother did that
what's the first place people are gonna
buy drugs at on the corner what's the
second place people are gonna do and
sell drugs at
the disco
it's the epitome and the era of disco
music
[Music]
it's three in the morning in manhattan
and still at studio 54 people crowd the
doors hoping to get in my mother like to
rub elbows with the elite of the time
society columnists adore studio 54 for
the personalities it attracts
studio 54 is practically on the joint
studio 54 was lined up for blocks
everybody started cocaine in there
[Music]
saturday i feel with senorita cocaine
[Music]
it took over america for the rich and
famous
the number of people snorting cocaine is
rising steadily despite the steep price
about a hundred dollars for a gram
enough for several people to get high at
one party
[Music]
cocaine paraphernalia is selling well
right on madison avenue who is buying
this
everyone
from the
secretary lawyers businessmen old and
young we have customers in the
entertainment business but most of them
are executives
[Music]
it's not a serious problem nationwide
given the very large number of people
who use cocaine it is a serious problem
for a certain small minority and those
tend to be people who are very wealthy
for whom money is is no concern who can
get unlimited access to cocaine
cocaine at that point really wasn't in
law enforcement's radar and so there was
a gap in the intelligence that was being
developed and this gave the colombians a
opportunity to establish a greater
foothold for smuggling the drugs into
the country and distributing the drugs
without being caught
my mother makes a fortune in new york
city and moves back to colombia
[Music]
and her and capitan see that their
empire has grown so much that they need
henchmen they need soldiers
and everybody knew that if you wanted to
get into the cocaine business you had to
get the green light from griselda
[Music]
pablo escobar's boss was one of those
smugglers
my mother didn't like him too much so
pablo killed him
and my mother said pablo you got a
future kid
it wasn't until later that i realized
what a role she played not only in the
cocaine business but also in the
business of violence
she was a psychopath
she
loved
killing people
in the beginning i really liked that he
was young and well-mannered and educated
he had an innocence about him also
i would describe my father as a rebel
adventurous man he was a chilled person
he loved his music he loved to be around
friends
peaceful sometimes introverted too
i figured a great guy to meet and to
work with and we can make a lot of money
together
the next thing i knew we were on our way
down to colombia to meet a guy named
pablo escobar
a lot of people asked me about inr or
whatever i mean he could have been a
vacuum cleaner sale so i didn't know who
the hell he was
we talked and he said
i have one rule
you betray me
and i'll have to kill you
and i said well
you'll never get to kill me because i'll
never betray you
i mean it's a simple rule right
you know people walking around the
rancho machine guns and this and that
that wasn't my trip
i
i just wanted to get in and get the hell
out of there
[Music]
[Music]
pablo escort
industrializes
the cocaine trade
he gathers
a big group of different traffickers
based in the city of medellin
[Music]
and they begin to pull their shipments
and work together
and then carlos leva brings the mass
transport element via planes
he provides me air bridge
then there's the retailers
others in the us
they are running the distribution
networks and then funneling back the
money to the cartel
[Music]
[Music]
carlos later is to the cocaine smuggling
business what the wright brothers were
to aviation
when i first met carlos it was simply to
purchase some airplanes for him
i never used my real name i went by an
alias
he got a hold of me and said hey i got
this place in the bahamas that's where
we're going to operate out of and i need
some airplanes so i picked up a couple
airplanes for them flew into the bahamas
and carlos said hey you want to fly down
to columbia fill them up and bring them
back to the islands and make a little
extra money and so i said okay
carlos was very convincing
you know the smile on his face and how
great it is so consequently you'd kind
of insidiously get involved in this i
mean i had no desire to be a criminal i
had no desire to go to jail
one of the most favored routes from
colombia to miami is via the bahamas
famous for its beaches casinos and
hundreds of thinly inhabited keys or
islands that have been used for
smuggling for centuries
[Music]
the flying was not nearly as dangerous
as hanging out there overnight in
columbia out of these little strips
around the middle of nowhere
i remember sleeping in a hammock with a
38 on my chest because there was some
people that would come in with automatic
weapons and steal the product
if you messed up
you weren't getting out if you as others
did crash an airplane at some of these
clandestine strips in columbia and you
were injured
the narcos buried you with the airplane
they didn't take you to the hospital
so there was a great incentive to
successfully land and take off
this is an old saying that marijuana
businesses come with a handshake
and the cocaine business was still with
a gun
people walking around with guns
and everybody had one
it was very serious
and mistakes weren't tolerated
[Music]
in the drugs business all roads lead to
miami florida america's biggest banking
center outside new york cocaine dealers
regularly pay cash for a fifty thousand
dollar car a one hundred thousand dollar
yacht or a million dollar condominium
one of the side effects of the cocaine
trade was the impact it had on the
economy and the
the amount of cash that was free flowing
[Music]
the money that was coming into miami was
just incredible
i remember we would have to go to the
federal reserve bank and there were just
pallets and pallets and pallets of cash
many times the federal reserve bank of
miami had more cash
than all the other federal reserves
banks put together
[Music]
he purchased norman's key for what i was
told at the time was two million dollars
so carlos had actually purchased the
island
and he wanted to build
like an empire there a drug smuggling
empire
using a front company he acquired most
of the property on the island and turned
it into a drug transshipment port it was
full of naked women parties
and cocaine everywhere
um bodyguards walking around the
perimeters
with machine guns which he imported from
from germany
norman's key was approximately 200 plus
miles from the east coast of florida
so it was a very easy trip for a light
airplane which would draw no suspicion
whatsoever because a light airplane
didn't have the range to go anywhere
where this merchandise was picked up
in the beginning it was all fine
then carlos changed drastically did like
a 180 and i told myself this is crazy
the other way to do this is to keep on
the move and keep changing locations
when nobody knows who you are what you
are and you keep moving
and i said
everybody in the world is going to be
watching that island
and they were
it was a madness
and that's when i decided it was
time to go
anybody who thinks they're a drug lord
they're living some kind of foolish
childish dream
once you get on the list
it's over
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
is
the first chicago motorcycle hit it was
done by griselda's killers and they
weren't young 15 year old 16 year old
boys they were grown by deals it was a
different time my mother never believed
that a boy should get involved in men's
stuff
[Music]
brazilian comes to miami you have an
industry that was trying to be
established
by other latinos
but now
this corporate entity came into town and
said no no this is my town i don't care
what you guys think i run all the
cocaine
my mother always told me you know what's
the best way to take care of your
competition erase your competition
then you have nobody to compete with
right now two people are dead and there
are others injured i don't know the
exact amount police say they don't know
what the motive was for the shootings
but they are sure it wasn't robbery
the shooting occurred in the middle of
the day in a very
popular shopping mall called dateland
inside the liquor store one colombian
national and another non-cube in latin
suspected of drug trafficking lay face
up in a pool of blood
they were well armed we can say that and
they came prepared to do battle
the subjects went inside with automatic
weapons
killed the intended target in his
bodyguard inside the liquor store the
shooting continued outside as the
assailant sprayed gunfire all around the
parking lot shell fragments were found
some 40 yards from the store
they'd fired automatic weapons into the
sidewalk area we'll need two other
totally innocent bystanders
witnesses were just beside themselves
they couldn't believe the fact that they
were in
minding their own business shopping at a
suburban shopping mall and ended up
being shot out with machine guns
it was totally unprecedented no one had
never seen anything like this before on
any homicide scene
this was the handiwork of griselda
blanco
she loved to make that statement
and the bloody trail continued from that
point on
that day 1979 i think miami
and the united states understood
that cocaine would generate so much
violence and so much financial gain that
people were willing to kill people in
broad daylight innocent or not innocent
[Music]
last week the bodies of two colombians
were found majority of murders here are
related to drug trafficking colombian
drug dealers have opened fire in crowded
shopping centers along busy highways in
quiet residential neighborhoods
this colombian was machine gunned as he
sat in his car
514 persons have been murdered in miami
this year
there's no end to the selection of
weapons that they have here they're a
lot better armed than law enforcement
we became known as dodge city
what i see going on here
would make chicago in the days of
prohibition look like a baptist sunday
school picnic
our homicide rate doubled from 300 a
year to 600 a year
we were all overwhelmed
not the least of which was the medical
examiner's office which had to use a
refrigerated truck to store bodies
the primary target of metro date
homicide was griselda blanco
she not only wanted the person shot but
she wanted the person's wife
and even the children shot
she was a monster
[Music]
initially he'd try a little bit of the
product occasionally but it got to the
point where he was i believe addicted to
it and i think that really distorted his
perception of what the operation was and
he became a different person
he was very paranoid he ran around with
the 45 waving it around he never knew
what the hell he was going to do he just
had this attitude that he was the king
that's when i decided that this could
get dangerous
it means time to say sayonara to this
activity
colombian drug baron carlos leder had
armed guards to prevent outsiders
landing by boat or plane
for yachtsmen this island had a menacing
reputation
sometime after i left one of the most
famous news anchors in north america
walter cronkite sailed into the harbor
at norman's key
and was met by a couple of fellows that
were sporting ar-15s and when he asked
what the deal was they told him that he
wasn't welcome on the island and he
should just get in his little boat and
sail on out of the harbor
cronkite
wasn't going to be put off like that so
he opened up his own little
investigation and one thing led to
another and eventually the bahamian
police were convinced by the u.s
authorities dean what have you that you
need to do something about this island
down there
[Music]
kos became a freudian kaleidoscope of
madness because on one of the spectrum
he loved john lennon
and he loved adolf hitler
and that was mind boggling to me
[Music]
it was on the news on the radio on the
streets we had the army coming to our
house
almost every day looking for him
[Music]
as she began to
create more and more enemies she wasn't
able to really enjoy the fruits of her
endeavors
because she was on the run
i would always wonder why we had so many
people with me
and my brother would tell me you know
why why because you're the prince of
this family
and nothing's gonna happen to you
[Music]
her husband dario sepulveda is growing
weary of her he's disgusted with her
talk about the pot calling the kettle
black right he's an assassin himself and
even she was too much for him
[Music]
he's worried about the well-being of his
son michael corleone
and he takes michael and goes to
columbia well griselda wasn't having any
of that
[Music]
and a short time later she pays off
police in columbia
is driving down a road with little
michael in the car
and after a couple minutes
four cops two motorcycles pull us over
he hey cause my father my father goes
what are you doing my father looks at
his bodyguard
and i think right then and there they
realized it
got that look at my daddy
that's your puppy puppy
my dad was hit by 27 bullets
i saw the holes on his back
and there was all blood coming out of
him
i was about to be six years old
[Music]
griselda blanco ordered the hit on her
husband and there's no doubt in my mind
that she didn't care whether her son saw
the assassination or not
[Music]
all he knew was that he was whisked up
put on a plane and delivered to his
mother in irvine california
and shortly thereafter
is when we arrest her
she was just propped up in bed reading
the bible she didn't have the 38 in her
hand that was on her nightstand i said
hola gore zelda she looked at me with a
very bewildered look
no
miyamo betty
i said nah i don't think so and i put
the cuffs on her away we went
the maid had taken little michael down
the street to go play at a park we
didn't want him in the house you know it
was going to be too traumatic
he was as cute as a button playing in a
playground
just a nice kid and it was so sad and i
remember commenting to my wife i said
you know i really feel sorry for this
child
i wouldn't mind taking this kid and
adopting him myself
[Music]
i only had the opportunity to meet
carlos leather for
one or two weeks in the hacienda
annapolis
they became very close friends
they were both against the extradition
they were very close but they always
kept their families away from everything
sadly carlos led her loose all of his
money and power and he was consuming a
lot of drugs
colombian law enforcement officers have
not said exactly how police were led to
later's house in medellin but that later
was set up by one of his alleged
partners in the cocaine cartel pablo
escobar
the story is that there was
a big party in pablo escobar's
arrived coked up
and
one of escobar's cardios makes a pass at
one of the girls he was with and later
just kills him
[Music]
and so escobar has to smooth all this
over
but elements of the medellin cartel then
see carlos as a liability
escobar sees the need to appease us and
colombian officials who are applying
increasing pressure on him and his
organization and leonard gets offered up
as the sacrificial lamb and essentially
turned over by escobar and medellin
cartel associates
i remember the day of my father's arrest
i was with my mother
and i can still feel how her face turned
white and the screams
the plane from columbia carrying reputed
drug king carlos later touched down in
florida early this morning security was
heavy gun-toting federal agents circled
the courthouse in temple where he was
taken justice department officials
described later as one of the most
violent drug dealers ever captured
[Music]
i was looking at more than 20 years in
prison
straight up the judge said when you were
young you had a hundred million dollars
and he said
nobody knew who you were why didn't you
just take it and go away
and
i had the answer because i had figured
it out a while back
that
it wasn't the money anymore my father
knew what was going on for years and he
said you're a true junkie he said why
don't you become a race car driver or
something like that
[Music]
eskimo sent my wife to visit me
and
she said he wants you to testify
and i said i won't she had my daughter
who's
four years old
and with her and
she looked at me and she said
this time he's not asking
[Music]
i was six years old when we needed to go
hide because escobar was looking for me
he knew the love that my father had for
me and the perfect way to silence him is
to threaten his little girl when his
trial started
you can't even imagine that it's
possible but
they say that at war
everything goes
[Music]
it is one of the biggest victories in
u.s history for drug agents and federal
prosecutors now that he's been convicted
later faces a life prison sentence plus
150 years on top of that
[Music]
they saw him as a trophy i say
he wrote his first letter and he
promised me that he would be home by
christmas
and now it's been a 33 christmas waiting
for him
[Music]
when you've done so much bad in your
life
that type of beef never goes away that
type of generational hatred revenge
don't go away
so after eight years of my mother's
release
she was killed
[Music]
some exclusive details for us brian tom
pablo escobar is without a doubt the
most powerful and ruthless of all the
drug bosses it's believed that his
cocaine empire has made escobar one of
the world's richest men worth estimated
at 3 billion escobar's ranch is a
monument to his illegal trade the plane
over the gate is the first to use to
transport illegal drugs those who would
challenge pablo at his own game learned
he would do anything to win cocaine
bought these 10 000 acres of mansions
and guest houses quite a haul for a man
who began his career stealing
gravestones and cars and working as a
golf caddy
foreign
[Music]
you